one of the things recently the last few
years there's been a lot of complaints
about the superhero genre and how
they're all the same and like whatever i
think this movie is a shining light of
to like as to what can be done like this
is a fantastic film that happens to star
batman you know the filmmaking on this
movie is is incredible could you sort of
talk about that aspect of it that it's
it's just a beautiful film
well i think you know matt really wanted
a grounded film uh
and
you know taking
just look on how the film opens
you don't know what that whose point of
view it is
and it's very mysterious and it has this
whole film noir
aspect to it that comes out of you know
the detective comics
and uh
you know and he also was sort of picking
up a moment in time where their
characters are becoming who they we who
we know later on as the penguin and
catwoman and batman
so
there's he was just interested in the
nuances of it and also how a crime is
solved and how batman you know hooks up
with with gordon and they're both trying
to
use each other and help each other
and i think it's
and then there's this subterranean world
you know and then it was like and then
there's a world sort of underneath that
too so i think
that's what he was interested in
in a way so
you know if i'm at the center of a film
it kind of ruins my opportunity to enjoy
it in any way as an audience member but
because i had the five or six scenes in
this i could really experience the film
as a fan of previous batman films and
just as a fan of film and cinema in
general
and as john said the first five minutes
i was just rattled that opening shot and
that perspective and as john said we
don't know whose
point of view we're looking at but it's
a very distinct point of view and we
hear the breath and it's creepy as hell
and there's a voice over and we're
introduced to gotham and it's an
incredibly sick place
and i think the sickness that's in
gotham is represented in all facets of
life the criminality of of the police
department in it the criminality of the
political um realm and also just common
thieves and
robert murderers on the street the
shadows are everywhere so i was just
overwhelmed by how immersive
a film this was you know and it's dark i
mean it's got weighty themes what's it
about i don't know it's not about one
thing but matt
and was very concerned with just
grounding it and making it all kind of
recognizable i mean when you look at the
world around us now it's a pretty
corrupt place and it's a pretty dark
place and the darkness is even gotham is
so sick it doesn't even hide its
darkness anymore it's just it's out in
the open um and batman has a lot to
a lot to square up against if he's going
to put a dent in that you know but uh
the emer the immersiveness of the
experience was astonishing for me you
know
i'm almost out of time but i have to ask
you i think that one of the highlights
of this film is greg frazier's
cinematography yeah it is breathtaking
could you both talk a little bit about
collaborating with him and maybe one of
the shots that really just impressed you
i mean almost every shot was was uh was
interesting you know and uh i mean just
looking at the windows of my office what
you know what was
here would be like the background uh
the loop that they had it looked like it
was real they were you looked
this looks like real streets and
it's really was uh
incredibly
uh done and it was and very dark at the
same time so you would people would come
in and out of the shadows
so you can you can pick that up pretty
quickly i think totally yeah and
sometimes you're not privy to the the
brilliance that's being expressed around
you when you're in the scene you know
there are times like um john's office
carmine's office that you can see how
extraordinary the the vista outside the
window the bridge the city is going to
look and there are other times when you
just don't know and then when you see
the film you go oh my god what a
painting and you just feel really glad
to be in a frame that looks as cool and
and as as rich and has the depth that
greg's work has on this film i think the
scene of batman upside down walking
towards
my fella in the car is is just
extraordinary you know the world turned
on its head the flames in the background
is so powerful
100 i have to ask you though colin real
quick the prosthetic job that mike did
for you to bring this the character to
life is so jaw-dropping amazing
did you want to like leave set in
costume and just sort of like walk
around and be anonymous or did yeah
i'm fair i feel like i'm fairly honest
man
you know if i hadn't known at the start
of my career i would have done more
independent films and you know you just
get left alone a bit um
but uh mike you've probably talked to
mike through the years have you he's
extraordinary he's bri he's just
brilliant his imagination and his
artistic ability his training and all
that kind of stuff on the job but just
his imagination and his drawings his
sketches are extraordinary so to be the
canvas for his brilliance to create this
visage that that is ours was amazing but
in answer to your question the first day
we tried the whole thing
out we took it for a drive a spin
metaphorically speaking and and we did
it in burbank it took about six or eight
hours it was a team of 10 or 15 people
and it was really fun steve it was
really fun i went into starbucks and um
i ordered myself a very on oz drink you
know
an oat milk latte with two stevia
sweeteners
and uh not that i wasn't a big drinker
but he does have a sw does have a sweet
tooth but uh yeah no and got a couple of
stairs but only because it's such an
imposing such an imposing look so i feel
my honest to god mike did so much of the
work for me and there's so much of the
heavy lifting you know
so just to be clear you went into
starbucks in the in the
the full outfit yeah the full-out bit in
the accent and yeah yeah
you know oat milk latte and blah blah
blah you know
that is amazing okay i got it i got a
rap but i'm just going to say again um i
really really sincere uh congrats thanks
man thanks really great movie thanks
steve
you